افاده مراسله الجزيره بمواصله الطائرات
الحربيه والاستطلاعيه تحليقها في سماء مدن
العاصمه فضلا عن سمائه اصوات سماع اصوات
مضادات ارضيه في جنوب ام درمان ووسط
الخرطوم في الاثناء قال مصدر في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان الجيش اسقط مسيرتين
اثناء محاوله الدعم السريع قصف سلاح
المدرعات بالخرطوم امس جربيه افاده مصدر
طبي سوداني بوقوع عدد من القتلى والجرحى
جراء قصف استهدف فجر اليوم منطقه حي
النهضه بضاحيه الانقاذ جنوبيه الخرطوم الى
ذلك استمرت لليوم السابع على التوالي
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد حول مخازن رئيسيه
للوقود جنوب العاصمه وقربه مصنع للصناعات
الدفاعيه يتبع للجيش كان قد شهد الاسبوع
الماضي اشتباكات عنيفه بين طرفي الازمه
اذا رقعتاء تطورات الميدانيه انتقلت الى
خارج الخرطوم حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
الجيش السوداني قصف للمره الاولى مواقع
تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في مدينه الاوبيض
عاصمه ولايه شمال كردفان وسط السودان
واضاف مراسلنا ان قوات الدعم السريع ردت
باطلاق مضادات الطيران وكانت المدينه شهدت
مواجهات بين الجانبين منذ بدء القتال
منتصف ابريل الماضي بدورها قالت مصادر
محليه للجزيره لمدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه
جنوب بادرفور شهدت امس معارك عنيفه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وفي غرب البلاد افاد مراسلنا على الحدود
السودانيه بسماع ذوي القذائف الثقيله على
مدار الساعات الماضيه في مدينه الجنينه
عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور السودانيه وفي
محيطها واضف مراد سكان مدينه
لا يعرف موقع اطلاقها في الداخل السوداني
على وجه التحديد وقال شهود وعياننا ان
استمرار اطلاق النار في الجنينه يحول دون
خروج معظم السكان من المدينه
من الخرطوم الان ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف
مراسل الجزيره اسامه السيد احمد اسامه
مرحبا بك معنا اذا اجمل لنا ابرز ملامح
هذا اليوم بالنسبه للاشتباكات الدائره
فيما يتعلق بتصورات الميجابيه الحكومه
الان يعني
مشروب بالحدث هذا الهدوء جميع جبهات
القتال المعتاده
يعني في كل من بحري والضمان
مباشره او غير مباشره ما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لكن طبعا
الطيران الحربي الساده للجيش السوداني
يعني يواصل تحقيقا استطلاعيا المستمره منذ
مساء امس وواصل حتى تعاطي صباح اليوم دون
اخفض اي اهداف ارضيه ولكن رغم ذلك يعني
سمعت اطلاق مضادات ارضيه لقوات الدعم
السريعه لمواقع متفرقه للعاصمه السودانيه
طبعا الواقع يعني الواقعه الميداني متحرك
بطبيعته وحدوث اي اشتباكات ما بين البيت
وقوات الدعم السريعه الامر لا يتبعت في اي
لبعض المواقع في اعاده من المناطق خاصه
منطقه قليل اضافه الى عده مواقع اخرى
بعض المواقع يعني اصبح مسرح مستمر
للقصفعي خاصه مناطق جنوب التي تسببت
مدفره سابقه اخرها كان مساء في موت عشرات
المدنيين حتى ان مستشفى بشائر الذي يقع
جنوبي العاصمه السودانيه
الجرحى جراء هذا الخط وهذا طبعا يثير قلقا
يعني مساله اختبار قص المدنيين هذه الذين
حتى لم يسلم بعضهم حتى وهم يحكمون
بمنازلهم يعني في تطورات ايضا لاحقه بحسب
مصدر عسكري يتحدث للجزيره افادها للبيت
السوداني تحدث الى الجزيره عن ان الجيش
السوداني تمكن من الاسقاط مسيرتين اثنين
اثناء محاوله قوات الدعم السريع امس سلاح
المدرعات بوسط الخرطوم العمليه الى مقتل
ضابط طبيب بحسب المصدر العسكري الذي يدفع
للجيش السوداني طبعا للمره الاولى منذ
بدايه الحرب هذه هي دور الحديث عن استخدام
قوات الدعم السريع لمسيرات لمهاجمه الجيش
السوداني طبعا ايضا في سياق هذه التطورات
المتلاحقه خارج الخرطوم بحسب مصادر في
مهنته ايضا فان الطيران الحربي السوداني
بالاساده للجنس السوداني قام بالتحليق هو
خط اهداف ارضيه في بعض الاماكن التي تمر
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع التي تتجمع
المدينه طبعا ايضا للمره الاولى يقوم
طيران الجيش السوداني بخطف اهداف في هذه
المنطقه ما يشير الى ان تطورات كثيره تحدث
على مدار الساعه واليوم في هذه الحربه
المستمره التي لم تصلح جميع الجهود
الدبلوماسيه الخارجيه والاقليميه والدوليه
من وقتها حتى هذه اللحظه حتى ان امتدادات
هذه الحربه المستمره امتدت لبعض ما منذ
خاصه مدينه انجلينا ومدينه
مدينه هذه تحديدا طبعا منفتحه ومنعدله
تماما
على العالم وعلى الحديث داخلها يدور
الاخبار التي تريدينها على سلتها تدور حول
ان الاوضاع الانسانيه اصبحت كارثيه للغايه
وفي ظل من اعدام كامل لاي خدمات وقطع
الاتصالات وانعدام المياه هو القطاع
الكهربائي والقتل حيث ان يعني منظمات
انسانيه اشارت الى انها اكثر من
1400 قتيل حتى هذه
اللحظه واكثر من الفين
وتعمئه يعني
ساقوم بحاجه
اسامه السيد احمد من الخرطوم